all right what's up mkbhd here so we got
a little surprise little quiet but not
so quiet addition to apple's holiday
season stuff a little one more thing on
top of there one more thing so they've
added to their headphone lineup and
there's a new pair of over ear
wireless
noise cancelling apple headphones and
they're called air pods max
and they cost
550 dollars
and i got them right here
now i didn't really know what to make of
the name right off the bat i don't think
i would have named them airpods
personally but hey if you look at the
rest of apple's lineup i guess all of
their audio products have pod in them
there's ear pods air pods home pods so
fine either way this is the box and it's
a pretty big box for a pair of
headphones but you can see we have this
minty green color here today to get into
when you pop that top get into the top
of the box first thing you see is the
headphones inside already inside the
smart case because they don't fold they
don't pack down at all this is how you
travel with them this is how they ship
in this case with the bands as a handle
but we'll get to that in a minute i'm
just gonna take them out of the case for
the first time and the metal of the
headphones is actually legit cold to the
touch which is pretty sweet not gonna
lie i can get the paper off of the smart
case so we can admire that too in all of
its
uh glory
anyway not much else in the box you get
a little bit of paperwork no apple
stickers and there is one cable but not
the typical cable that comes with
headphones no this is a usb type-c to
lightning cable there is no brick and
this is purely for charging and there's
no audio cable included that'll be
another 35 bucks from apple.com
but yeah there you have the headphones
pretty unique uh they look like those
huge planar magnetic headphones from
back in the day but like a modernized
version of that design i guess it's kind
of classic this green here probably
isn't the best looking color if i'm
being real but that's it we can get it
back into the smart case slap that
magnet shut and we're off to the races
[Music]
so it turns out
there is a lot of really interesting
stuff
with this particular pair of headphones
i mean you guys have seen headphones
before i've reviewed them but
there's a lot that's different a lot
that's unique about these that you don't
really see very often
and so while this isn't my review uh
that'll be coming up soon and definitely
make sure you subscribe to be among the
first to see that if you haven't already
uh this is just gonna be my first
impressions and the top five things you
should know
about these new airpods so number one
the materials like i said when i took it
out the box the metal was cold to the
touch so these have a stainless steel
flexible frame and the ear cups i was
touching are aluminum there's these
shiny telescoping arms and ball head
joints on the ear cups that let them
move around a little over 90 degrees
overall there is no doubt these are
built very well there's no creaks no
gaps anywhere i mean even the little
slide to expand the headphones is really
satisfying because there's a lot of
resistance and i think i actually like
this more than the typical plastic
clicks to expand but really the
materials aren't actually as important
as the overall comfort and these are
going to sit on top of the head pretty
nice that mesh band at the top is
basically designed to distribute the
weight as evenly as possible across your
head and be kind of breathable and it is
really soft which is awesome but we'll
see about durability long term
i think it's probably worth it though
because with all this metal
they are heavy headphones they come in
at a hefty
386 grams compared to the much lighter
250 grams of my sony xm4s but yeah i
mean as far as just high-grade
headphones go aside from this one's
particular lack of sweat or water
resistance
it just doesn't get much better built
than this that's just facts by the way
the color options same as the ipad air
so black silver
light blue
pink and this sort of minty green all
right number two
the ear cups
magnetic
so they just pop off pretty easily they
do stay on really well in their sort of
groove when you're wearing them and
obviously most of the time they don't
just flop off but when you really do
pull them to take them off
they come off and that's actually really
smart because most people should replace
the ear cups on their headphones every
once in a while the metal part the
outside that's designed to last a long
time but the inside especially with
softer materials and leathers you see
that a lot people sort of
outgrow the ear pad and then just buy
new headphones so this
is a good idea now apple is very happy
to sell you some new ear pads for
sixty
a set
but uh i guess a nice bonus at least is
that you can actually mix and match
colors if you want to
would have been nice if you could
customize your cushion color straight
from the order page and mac rumors even
put together a little visual aid so you
can see what the different color combos
look like but that's just the most apple
thing you've ever heard isn't it buying
550 headphones
and having to spend an extra 70 dollars
to change part of the color but number
three is the controls so there are no
touch controls anywhere on the sides of
either of the earcups as there are with
a lot of other wireless headphones
instead they borrow the digital crown
from the apple watch plus there's an
extra noise cancellation button just to
go on or off with transparency or noise
cancellation i might have preferred to
see these buttons at the bottom of the
ear cups for better reachability but
overall this is probably honestly better
than a lot of the finicky touch controls
i like when there's a physical control
like on microsoft's headphones having
that big dial spinning that was sweet
too so here on the apple headphones you
can spin that digital crown for volume
you can tap it in to answer calls or
double tap to go forward triple tap to
go back etc and also in ios 14.3 when
you update there's uh controls and
support built in that let you reverse
the scrolling direction for the crown in
case you end up getting it backwards
then number four
the case
so uh let's just get the jokes out of
the way right off the top shall we it
looks like a purse that doesn't really
hold much
and it looks like a bra like no way
around it but for real this is a super
strange case to me so they call it the
smart case it comes with the headphones
and the headphones literally just slot
in here and close with a magnet and my
very first impression is
there is
no redeeming quality about this case at
all the headphones don't actually fold
down or get more compact to travel with
the most durable part of the headphone
is covered and the softest least durable
part is your carrying strap it's the
most exposed part
and then it isn't even fully protect all
of it there's like slots in here i
understand you can charge here if you
want to plug them in via lightning but
what is all this what this this case is
weird and then also something to note
there is no on off button with these
headphones so instead you put them in
this case and when the magnet shuts it
detects that they're in the case and
they go okay we don't need to be on
anymore it goes into this ultra low
power state to save battery and that's
cool that's really smart and that means
you don't have to remember to turn them
off every time and as soon as you take
them out the case they wake up and it's
like you never turn them off easy
but now that means you have to use this
case to turn the headphones off and if
you don't use this case they will just
sit around draining battery for about
two hours before they go into auto low
power mode
not sure if other cases can be made that
also use magnets to trigger this low
power mode that remains to be seen but
then number five last but not least is
the smart features so this is the part
that's going to require the most
additional testing for me because
basically aside from sound quality which
first impression is very good and noise
cancellation is right about on par with
airpods pro basically they're incredibly
good with white noise but there's a lot
more testing for this sort of thing for
the full review
and
there's a lot of smart features too
there's the dual h1 chips doing a lot of
computing as you listen to music one in
each ear there's nine microphones this
time for noise cancellation and
transparency mode and they're of course
apple headphones made to be used with
iphones and apple products so when you
use it with an iphone you get features
like audio sharing
siri you're reading your text messages
and the instant pairing and all that fun
stuff but like i said i'm going to get
super into this and the audio quality
and in-depth thoughts on all this stuff
in the full review this is just the
impression and there's a lot of testing
to be done but at the end of the day you
know what's the hardest part for me
about these
is i i don't really know
what exactly to compare them to like of
course i plan on putting them through
the ringer and and very thoroughly
testing them because at 550 dollars they
deserve that and you deserve that but i
guess i want to hear from you in the
comments section what you specifically
want to know about these headphones what
do you care about with headphones like
this like my natural instinct as you
probably saw on twitter was to compare
them to
my precious my i mean a lot of people's
favorite wireless headphones ever which
is the sony's and the xm4s they're
basically the top of the line industry
favorite noise canceling wireless
headphones and as you know those
headphones have the absolute best noise
cancellation i've ever heard they're
lightweight and comfortable they have a
longer 30 hour battery life they
actually fold for travel they come with
a real protective case they come with an
audio cable and they're 200
less at their absolute maximum of 350
bucks but you can already find them for
less than that so by that logic at least
on paper sony's headphones absolutely
beat apple's headphones in pretty much
every metric right
but i feel like a lot of people aren't
going to use that as a comparison
interestingly enough maybe
maybe it's like the pro display xdr
where you have to compare it to the
super ultra high end reference grade
stuff
to appreciate it so if i'm comparing it
to my two thousand four hundred dollar
sennheiser headphones that i've edited
with
maybe this
is a lighter weight
wireless
smaller
cheaper version of that that works with
more devices
maybe that's the comparison or maybe it
is somewhere in the middle with like you
know the sennheiser hd 650 or even the
drop thx panda headphones somewhere in
that high-end audio file range except
now it's just apple's entry into that
space it's hard to say but at the end of
the day if you're here from my take for
my first impression i have listened to
these for a couple hours now and
they sound really good but do they sound
550
good
i mean you're starting to approach the
limits of wireless audio so tbd
um they are built extremely well but
does that alone make them worth
550 dollars
not really um they of course have all
apple smart features and i don't think
that by itself is going to make you buy
headphones that expensive but maybe all
of this stuff combined
maybe just maybe all that put together
well there's an audience for it because
they're sold out already but either way
i hope to find that out all in the full
review this has just been my first look
first impressions of airpods max a weird
name i'm not going to get used to saying
that for a while but
again let me know what you think what
you want to know about these headphones
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace